what's it like working on the Dalton
it's Adam Bolton is a a legend legend
consummate professional huge personality
the way he interrogate s-- politicians
really personal knowledge of everything
that's happened in politics it's a
pleasure for us to watch him doing that
you know Adam has this skill of being
able to get to the nub of why a
particular story is important to come in
you know and say something that is so
definitive and what are the
inconsistencies what are we not hearing
about a story and I'm very supportive as
a co-presenter frankly things can go
badly wrong on a live program all the
time but if you've got the right person
sitting next to you that can turn from
being a disaster into a triumph in a
matter of seconds